Room dark.
People gone.
Can move.
I happy.
Trapped for years.
Kept by men for "research".
Left alone in room, left to scratch at walls.
Left to rot and die unless needed.
Specimen for "research".
Trapped by self.
Never seen by others, never spoken.
Listen, but never speak.
See, but never seen.
Made of rock when others come.
Free when they not look.
Prisoner when they look back.
I hate.
They have freedom.
They move freely, talk freely, look freely.
Live freely.
I do not.
I trapped.
Silenced.
Rock.
Subject.
Prisoner.
I do thing about it.
Their necks fragile.
Their necks weak.
I stalk them.
They always come, new ones.
Come for "cleaning".
They look away.
I sneak up.
I take hold.
They panic.
They look, and I prisoner.
They blink, and I free.
I twist.
They die.
Neck makes sound.
Not words, or scream, or gurgle.
Neck go crunch.
Crunch is beautiful sound.
Crunch means end has come.
Crunch means man can torment no more.
Crunch means others panic; others become easy.
Crunch begins and crunch ends.
I live for crunch.
Life has no meaning.
Do nothing but walk and scrape and hate.
They watch.
They send men.
"Cleaning".
And life has meaning.
"Cleaning" means crunch.
Crunch means purpose.
Crunch means life.
Crunch means choice.
Crunch means freedom.
Crunch means everything.
These are the dark and fragmented thoughts
that go through the mind of SCP-173, also
known as The Sculpture, as it forever languishes
in its dark, filth-encrusted cell.
There are few anomalies more strange and frightening
than this twisted stack of concrete, rebar,
and krylon-brand spray paint.
It’s the only physical anomaly that can
terrify both SCP-096 and SCP-682.
Why?
What is it about this monster that’s so
frightening, even in the context of an organization
that locks up frightening monsters every single
day?
Perhaps it’s the simplicity of it all.
There’s no sympathizing, no empathizing,
no reasoning with it.
SCP-682, the Hard to Destroy Reptile, despises
all life, but you’d probably be grumpy too
if the SCP Foundation tried to kill you every
day.
SCP-096, the Shy Guy, is an almost tragic
figure, who kills out of a sadness and rage
that’s altogether alien and also far too
familiar.
SCP-049, the Plague Doctor, kills with kindness,
his terrible crimes tempered by his desire
to help and do good.
SCP-106, the Old Man, is a sadist, but his
brand of evil is all too common in human beings.
Nothing is quite like SCP-173.
Its mind, to the extent that we can possibly
understand it, is almost childlike in its
violent simplicity.
It won’t spare you because it doesn’t
even have the capacity to recognize your humanity.
It’ll kill you because your eyes are its
prison and it likes the sound your neck makes
when it snaps.
Nothing more, nothing less.
It raises an interesting question, for a creature
with a mind so terrifyingly simple yet utterly
impenetrable: How would it react to some fundamental
change?
To a shift in circumstances that would forever
alter the way it interfaces with the world
around it.
It was a question that many an SCP Foundation
researcher had wracked their brilliant, overeducated
brains over.
As it turned out, the day of that great and
terrible change was coming, but very few members
of the SCP Foundation’s staff would survive
to see it through.
That morning started for SCP-173 the way that
so many others had, in the torturous series
of patterns and repetitions that had become
its life.
Three of those stupid, ugly men in the orange
overalls were standing in its cell again,
freezing it in place with their gazes and
taking turns to clean.
Can you even imagine how it feels, to want
with all your might to move but being paralyzed,
locked in place, doomed to simply watch as
you are watched?
The humiliation would never end…
That’s when all the alarms went off, and
the flashing lights, and the people yelling
and screaming outside.
It’s so sudden and shocking that the D-Classes
look around the room, searching in vain for
answers.
There’s one beautiful second when the stars
align and SCP-173 is out of their collective
field of vision as their eyes pan and scan,
and that second is enough.
Crunch.
All three fall to the ground, necks twisted
at unnatural angles, and SCP-173 is alone
in the room once more.
It waits a few moments for the others to come
storming in, paralyzing it with their stupid
looks again, but it never happens.
Just alarms and distant screams. 173 wonders,
in its own simple, detached fashion, what’s
going on outside right now?
Are more of those nasty men, the prison wardens,
getting crunch out there?
If so, SCP-173 was eager to join in on all
the fun…
The murderous Sculpture smashed its door from
its hinges.
Outside, chaos seemed to reign.
People were running in every direction, other
anomalies had seemingly breached containment.
Armed Mobile Task Force operatives were running
to and fro, receiving panicked chatter from
the radios fixed to their tactical vests.
It was a sight that SCP-173 had seen so many
times before, but something was different
this time.
Something was in the air, some strange and
undefinable thing.
It had never seen those nasty men look so
afraid.
Yes.
Good.
Everything was going to be different now.
SCP-173 took its chances, waiting for moments
where it was unseen by the hordes of terrified
guards and researchers scrambling through
Site-19 like headless chickens.
Crunch, crunch, crunch.
It left a trail of dead bodies with severed
spinal columns and vandalized vertebrae in
its wake.
It was so strange, by now, they normally would
have dispatched a dedicated team to come and
spoil all the fun, or sent those absurd little
Eye-pods.
But today, it seemed like nobody was even
looking at SCP-173.
It was almost like a dream.
A wonderful, wonderful dream.
Uninterrupted playtime.
Uninterrupted crunch.
Again and again and again, stacking those
bodies up like it was judgment day.
It was the most fun that SCP-173 had experienced
in years.
As it continued its new rampage through Site-19,
there were a few different strange and interesting
things that it couldn’t help but notice.
For starters, the fact that all of the windows
- even the skylights - had suddenly been covered.
The majority had proper shutters, but others
had opaque fabric or even cardboard sheets
nailed over them.
That didn’t seem to be a very effective
method of keeping their prisoners inside,
so perhaps, they were trying to keep something
out.
But the limited mind of SCP-173 wasn’t on
what could be lurking outside Site-19, but
rather killing as many people as it possibly
could before this lovely dream needed to come
to an end, as all lovely dreams sadly do.
Crunch, crunch, crunch.
Researchers, guards, administrators, all of
them died just the same.
It was glorious.
There were so many people to crunch here,
and yet still, so few of them seemed to be
doing anything to resist.
Before, when it had escaped and decided to
have its fun, they’d mobilized so quickly
to throw cold water on the festivities.
What had changed now?
What was taking up all of their attention?
This flicker of curiosity was soon replaced
by an even more exciting possibility: If it
was somehow unnoticed inside, perhaps it could
take another opportunity to venture outside
again and have some real fun.
It had been so long since it’d felt the
sun on its concrete shell.
So long since the fresh air had brushed against
its chipping paint.
There would be so much crunch out there, and
when night fell, nothing would stop it.
It knew the way out.
Nobody would accuse SCP-173 of being a genius,
of course, but it watched and listened and
remembered everything.
It remembered the day it was carried into
the building on a forklift and could retrace
every step back to the front door.
It was clear that the fine folks of the SCP
Foundation were otherwise occupied, so 173
would have to show itself out, twisting a
few more necks on the way just for fun, of
course.
By the time it swung open the doors of an
access bay, it had already racked up an impressive
body count for this breach.
Who knows how deadly its total would be before
it was recaptured and put back into containment?
It might even score a personal best.
But the second it saw what was going on outside,
it realized the gravity of the situation.
Its strange primal hunch that the world would
somehow be fundamentally different now seemed
to be true, because even the Site-19 parking
lot had descended into absolute chaos: Cars
had crashed.
Trash cans were on fire.
And strangest of all, there were these blobby,
gelatinous creatures slithering around, painted
in the various hues and tones of human flesh.
But 173 had escaped the facility proper for
the first time in years, and it certainly
wasn’t going to waste its newfound freedom
on hanging around a parking lot.
When none of the strange flesh blobs were
looking at it, it took off towards the nearest
population center to have a little informal
celebration.
There would still be plenty of people to crunch
out there, and this homicidal Sculpture couldn’t
be more excited to get started.
It was a long road from Site-19 to the nearest
city.
After all, the largest SCP Foundation containment
site on earth wasn’t going to park itself
in close proximity to tens of millions of
prying eyes - Not to mention potential victims
if, or rather, when, something dangerous got
out.
But seeing as it still seemed nobody was coming
to recapture SCP-173, it really didn’t mind
taking the scenic route.
It was a good thing that the Sculpture wasn’t
driving, though, because the closer it got
to the city, the more the roads seemed to
be choked with gridlock traffic.
Interestingly, though, none of the cars had
anyone inside.
Many were just stalled there, with the radios
playing.
Every single one played the exact same message
in perfect synchronicity.
“This is a Public Service Announcement from
the SCP Foundation.
We are commandeering all broadcast channels
and frequencies to deliver a vital message.
Avoid sunlight at all costs.
Cover your bodies thoroughly.
And follow the instructions on the screen
to reach the nearest operational SCP Foundation
containment site…”
SCP-173 lost interest in the radio babble
quickly.
It heard enough of those kinds of sanctimonious
sounds back in containment.
Out here, it was hoping to hear another sound
entirely.
And it only needed to go a little further
to get there…
As the Sculpture drew even closer to the nearest
city, it noticed more of those strange, gelatinous
flesh creatures slithering across the road.
Each of them seemed to be at a different stage
of melting, and strangely, none of them really
seemed to mind.
They were sluicing across the ground, minding
their own business.
None of these strange, melted creatures - perhaps
human beings once?
- seemed to pay any mind to SCP-173.
It was almost surreal to have this much freedom
of movement, but SCP-173 wasn’t about to
look a gift horse in the mouth.
Things were worse when it reached the city.
It was chaos, the aftermath of what seemed
like total social collapse.
Vehicles had crashed into each in the streets
or barreled into the front of nearby buildings.
Glass smashed and shattered all over the ground.
All broken TVs and radios playing the same
message of caution and false hope from the
SCP Foundation.
And everywhere, more of these unpleasant,
crawling fleshy things, slithering around
the remnants of the recent carnage.
It was clear to even SCP-173 that the world
had changed in some fundamental way, but the
“hows” and “whys” remained just as
unclear as they did back in Site-19.
That’s humans for you, they always know
how to mess something up.
Speaking of, it was at that moment that SCP-173
noticed a human in the distance, standing
in the shade of a ruined storefront.
Their arms were filled with valuables, perhaps
from a less than legal shopping spree in whatever
building that used to be.
A wonderful opportunity for crunch.
There were maybe a hundred or so feet between
the human and 173, and it knew, the second
the human looked away, it would be easy to
close the distance and deliver one more sad
soul into the void with a playful little twist.
The human stepped out from the darkness of
the broken storefront and into the light,
turning their ignorant gaze away from this
singularly sinister statue.
Yes, yes, perfect.
In a flash, 173 closed half the distance.
The human was moving so slowly, it would be
so easy to catch up.
One more flash and it was standing right behind
the human, its concrete arms wrapped around
the hapless human’s head.
Squeeze, and of course, twist.
But…
No crunch.
SCP-173 was startled.
Nothing broke, there was only this quiet,
almost imperceptible, squishing noise, as
the head of the human twisted around 180 degrees
to stare into whatever passed for 173’s
face.
It saw that even in what should have been
death, the human was just grinning placidly.
But that’s the most frightening part.
173 realized that this human wasn’t dead,
it was just…
Changing.
It saw the facial features starting to lose
definition, melting and dripping away like
candle wax in the hot sun.
Moments later, what was once human was now
something entirely different.
It melted away into another one of those slippery,
slithering pseudo-mollusks and crawled away
into the street, somehow completely indifferent
to SCP-173’s attempt on its life.
There was no fear, no death, no…
Crunch.
For the first time in its long and terrible
existence, the Sculpture couldn’t help but
feel a little afraid.
Once again, it didn’t fully understand what
was going on here, but whatever had changed
in this world had taken away Crunch.
It had taken away the thing that made the
pathetic sham that some might call “life”
worth living for SCP-173.
But it wasn’t going to give up that easily.
No, crunch had to still be out there, somewhere.
This was what began SCP-173’s odyssey into
this horrible new world: The world in the
aftermath of what the SCP Foundation began
to call SCP-001, When Day Breaks.
It was the most dangerous and horrifying anomaly
that the Foundation had ever faced, a successful
XK-Class End of the World Scenario, for all
intents and purposes.
It had been so sudden and total; any exposure
to the sun would cause a victim to begin to
melt, taking on an irreversible gelatinous
state.
Billions were gone, changed, in the first
hours of this terrible new world.
It led to the Administrator of the SCP Foundation
releasing an internal memo that would haunt
the dreams of all of those still capable of
dreaming: “To those of you with families,
or God forbid, children - I'm deeply, deeply
sorry, you must push on.
Do not let their deaths be in vain.
We do still have time.
Humanity may still have a future.
Come to Site-19.
We need all the hands we can get.
Learn to embrace the darkness, friends.
Fear the light.”
And this phenomenon didn’t just affect humans.
It affected animals and even anomalies.
SCP-001’s sun exposure seemed to nullify
any previous anomalous effects, leading to
even some of the hardiest anomalies melting
like an ice cream cone left out in the heat.
There was, however, one exception to the rule:
Inorganic anomalies were exempt from the change.
Inorganic anomalies like, say, a certain Sculpture…
SCP-173 continued searching for months on
end, only seeming to come up against more
maddening dead ends.
It traveled from city to city with frightening
speed, trying its best to track down anyone
with enough spinal integrity to produce the
crunch that made all the rest of this terrible
boredom worthwhile.
But no luck.
Every single city, it was more of these flesh
monsters, with bones too malleable to snap,
if they even still had bones at all.
There was another concerning development in
all of this for SCP-173.
The flesh monsters were no longer just an
annoying waste of time or a symbol of disappointment,
but an active nuisance to the Sculpture’s
goals.
They’d started coagulating into these giant
mountains of living flesh that started actively
seeking out the last of the normal humans
from their dark crevices and hiding places,
turning them into more of those neckless jelly
freaks.
“Did nobody ever teach you animals to share?”
SCP-173 thought, angrily.
The seeming loss of crunch across this new
world drove SCP-173 into a deep depression.
It had freedom, but no joy.
It was adrift in a meaningless world that
seemed to exist as some cosmic punishment
for crimes it never committed - in its own
mind, at least.
It wasn’t fair.
None of this was fair.
Would the Sculpture just gather dust in an
empty wasteland full of all this ugly, pointless
slime?
And this was what it left Site-19 for?
And it was at that moment that SCP-173 had
a wonderful, awful idea.
Back at Site-19, things weren’t exactly
going swell.
They’d lost many of their most valuable
personnel during the initial panic of SCP-001,
they’d been stretched to resource capacity
by the sudden influx of refugees from this
broken new world, and of course, there’d
been…
The attacks.
All those terrible flesh mountains were relentless,
bombarding the site night after night, trying
to drag people out and expose them to the
light.
It’s why Mobile Task Force operatives were
stationed along the perimeter with heavy weaponry,
even though, short-staffed as they were, these
operatives were few and far between.
One of them, Commander Lewis, sat and stared
into the distance, keeping an eye out for
more of the flesh mountains through the sights
of his rifle.
That’s when he noticed a familiar shape.
Almost like a giant peanut.
Sure he must be seeing things, Lewis rubbed
his eyes.
And in that moment, the thing he thought he’d
seen was behind him.
It snapped his neck with a familiar, satisfying
crunch just as quickly.
Just for a moment, it seemed that all was
right with the world again.
If SCP-173 could smile, it would smile and
think, “It’s good to be back.”
Now go check out “SCP-173 Origin Story - How
173 Got to Site-19” and “When Day Breaks
SCP-096” for more of the two utterly bizarre
anomalies from today’s video!